bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus dans
votre journal de l'afrique à la une de
l'actualité le départ des forces
françaises et européennes du mali 2 face
à la menace terroriste paris avait
déployé ses hommes il ya neuf ans le
calendrier de ce retrait reste à
préciser on ne viendra avec le bakary a
semblé notre invité dans cette édition
au coeur de l'action sera non plus mali
et le niger emmanuel ma croire confirme
un repositionnement des soldes dont pays
sauf que l'avenue ses troupes étrangères
est vue avec méfiance vous entendrez
quelques réactions et puis le continent
attire les investisseurs du moyen-orient
300 entreprises émirati sont aujourd'hui
implantées en afrique elles fleurissent
dans différents secteurs celui des
énergies renouvelables en particulier
reportage au taureau à la fin de cette
édition
pas de réaction devant la presse mais un
simple communiqué dans lequel le pouvoir
en place à bamako se dit prêt à
travailler avec tous les partenaires
disposés à sécuriser et le mali
l'invitation ne concerne que les états
européens membres de la force takouba
alors même que ce groupement se prépare
à quitter le territoire au même titre
que barkan le rappel des faits avec axel
ciment
le départ de l'armée française du mali
est confirmée véritable casse tête
logistique le retrait s'étalera sur une
durée de quatre à six mois d'après le
président de la république
il sera effectuée de manière ordonnée
avec les forces armées maliennes et avec
la mission des nations unies au mali
durant cette période nous maintiendrons
nos missions de soutien au profit de la
minus mans concrètement les trois bases
de gao gossip et ménaka seront donc vidé
soit 2400 soldats français de
l'opération barkan qui participe depuis
2014 à la trappe des groupes jihadistes
dans le sahel au delà de barkan le
retrait français va également entraîner
la fin des forces spéciales takouba créé
il y a moins de deux ans les militaires
européens y participant seront
repositionnées dans la région
frontalière du mali
avec l'accord des autorités nigériennes
des éléments européens seront
repositionnées aux côtés des forces
armées nigériennes
dans la région frontalière du mali
paris réaffirme toutefois vouloir rester
engagé avec les européens auprès des
pays sahéliens et du golfe de guinée
pour poursuivre la lutte contre le
terrorisme aux côtés du président
ghanéen et du conseil européen le
président sénégalais présents à la
conférence de presse a indiqué
comprendre la décision française nous
avons convenu avec l'euro que la lutte
conte le serbe contre le terrorisme au
sahel ne serait être la seule affaire de
pays africains et l'abc sans consensus
que un engagement a été renouvelée de
rester dans la région de l'ertms que le
dispositif
paris a promis de coordonner son retrait
non seulement avec la mission de l'onu
au mali la minus ma mais aussi avec la
mission de formation de l'union
européenne au mali le utm qui
continueront de bénéficier d'un soutien
aérien et médical français sur place
avant le transfert ultérieur et
définitive de ses moyens
bamako la capitale certains considèrent
maintenant qu'il revient aux forces
armées maliennes de prendre le relais et
de couvrir tout le territoire à d'autres
sont en revanche plus sceptique la
correspondance d'un de fleurs lespiau à
bamako l'annnonce du retrait de marquer
n'était une surprise pour personne
des annonces qui était attendu et même
souhaité par une large partie de la
population malienne qui dénoncent
l'enlisement de l'armée française neuf
ans après le début de son intervention
au mali une armée qui n'a pas réussi à
fournir une réponse à la crise
sécuritaire d'autres au sein de la
classe politique d'opposition s'inquiète
de l'isolément du pays un pays pivot au
coeur du sahel qui a besoin je cite de
tous ses fils et de tous ses partenaires
je vous propose d'écouter l'un des
membres du cadre des changes sur les
potentielles conséquences du vide laissé
par barkan sur le plan sécuritaire ce
qui est à craindre c'est que les
dialyses demain ne se regroupent et
trouver un boulevard devant deux pour
envoyer le nord et le et le centre du
mali où ils sont déjà tapis disséminés
dans les populations je pense qu'ils se
le groupe pas parce qu'il ya cette fois
c'est cette présence étrangère qui est
dissuasive demain avec le départ des
forces de combat quand est-ce qu'ils
vont pas se grouper pour renvoyer le
money et s'ils le font et ce que l'armée
malienne aujourd'hui a les moyens de les
arrêter de les contrer des forces de
sécurité qui oeuvrait jusqu alors aux
côtés de l'armée française déployés dans
le nord du mali quels seront les impacts
sur les populations qui sont
régulièrement ciblés par les groupes
djihadistes qui s'affrontent dans la
zone pour cet habitant de gao dont nous
avons décidé de protéger l'identité pour
des raisons de sécurité l'heure est à
l'incertitude plus prisées du pilat
et si la disposition
en vide qui pose également la question
de l'engagement sur le terrain des
autres partenaires internationaux dont
la mission de maintien de la paix au
mali qui bénéficie de l'appui de barkan
en cas de problème des partenaires qui
font régulièrement l'objet d'attaqués
sur le terrain il y en a justement
s'intéresser à l'avenir sur le terrain
entre autres avec vous bakary sambe
bonsoir à vous êtes le directeur
régional du team du tout institute à à
dakar merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation
de france 24 alors tout à l'heure
pendant la conférence de presse qui
avait suivi l'annoncé officielle de ce
départ des forces françaises et
européennes emmanuel macron récusé le
terme d'échec est ce qu'il est dans le
déni la le président français ce qu'il
n'y a pas tout de même un échec relatif
oui vous savez la difficulté pour la
france au sahel j'ai tout le temps de
devoir gérer l'urgence et l'histoire en
même temps c'est vrai que c'est un
engagement français qui s'étaient sous
pression et qui finit derrière sous
pression a été sur le plan
communicationnel mal encadrée et je
pense qu'il ya eu tout le temps ce
conflit de perception du conflit
sahélien entre les populations locales
les acteurs internationaux et je pense
que la france véritablement avait perdu
la bataille de la communication depuis
très très longtemps mais je crois que ce
n'est pas en tant que tel barkan qui est
un échec mais celle approche tournée
vers le tout sécuritaire qui est un
échec parce que le terrorisme ne se
combat pas seulement par les armes il
faut s'attaquer aux causes structurelles
et on n'a pas fait cet effort de scinder
la problématique dans deux cantons du
bac la lutte contre le terrorisme
oui qui ne l'a pas fait cet effort là
les partenaires européens ne l'ont pas
fait mais je pense qu'aussi ils ont
entraîné dans leur sillage leurs
partenaires africains vous savez il ya
plus de vingt stratégie celle
plus de 18 de ces stratégies ont été
conçu hors du sahel et sans les
sahéliens je crois qu'on n'a jamais
essayé de donner la dignité de solutions
aux stratégies endogène écouter les
populations locales et je crois que
c'est ça qui c'est qui s'est répercutée
maintenant sur la vision des populations
locales sur barques en qui je le
rappelle comme l'audi les plats chauds
le chaos joué un rôle très important sur
le plan logistique mais aussi sur le
plan d'appui à la communauté
internationale et aux intervenants au
mali les populations à gao le témoignage
que l'on vient d'entendre notamment la
personne jointe par notre correspondante
disait que barkan rassurer la population
si je vous suis bien la prise en
considération de ces populations plus
largement dans tout le sahel est ce
qu'il y a aussi une part de
responsabilité aujourd'hui qui incombe à
la junte arrivée au pouvoir au mal y
esquisse a pu peut-être précipité ce
départ sous pression comme vous le
disiez vous même je pense qu'il faudrait
aussi partager les responsabilités
il ya toute une communication pour
dénigrer cette mission et c'est
l'intervention mais aussi c'est vrai que
cette mission a fait défaut à ses échecs
mais je pense que il est plus aisé de
critiquer l'opération barkan et critiqué
l'intervention des forces françaises et
d'autres forces européennes quand on est
à vos côtés quand on est confronté à
l'insécurité permanente dans ces zones
trans frontalière où les populations
vivent les conditions draconiennes des
mesures sécuritaires mais intense en
insécurité je pars aujourd'hui
l'art et de sincérité s'impose et je
pense que c'est un excellent débattu à
pau dans un sommet précédent où il ya
aussi la difficulté la duplicité dans le
discours de certains chefs d'état
africains qui font appel à la france
quand il y avait eu vent sécuritaire
mais qui en même temps au parc aux
populations n'assume pas cette
coopération là et cela a rajouté duflot
au flou et je crois que avec la
désinformation qui est une réalité
quotidienne sur les réseaux sociaux et
avec l'arrivée de nouveaux partenaires
pourquoi le mais c'est les russes je
crois que la situation s'est dégradée en
même temps que la communication ne
perdez en efficience en tout cas elle
n'a jamais été efficaces sinon on ose
dire et dans tout cela nous sommes
devant une pression qui pousse l'armée
française par darren est un coup bas à
se retirer du mali et l'ajustement et à
se repositionner par bakary sambe ccc
c'est très intéressant tout ce que vous
développez mais comme nous sommes un peu
pris par le temps je voudrais justement
vous faire réagir à certaines réactions
recueillies par nos équipes à niamey sur
la perspective de ce déploiement de
troupes dans le pays on les écoute on se
reparle
du compte tout plaisance militaire est
érigée
sur le territoire du niger parce que sa
menace la souveraineté nationale et la
force et au barca sincèrement nous
devons tirer de conséquences de leur
présence lorsqu'il était au mali et les
gens ne sont pas du tout confiants les
gens ne sont pas du tout confiants est
ce que c'est une bonne stratégie là que
de se redéployer au niger ont
manifestement la population est assez
hostile à cette arrivée de la même
manière que le pinceau serval avait
commencé sous la pression ce
redéploiement s'est fait sous la
pression c'est à dire je ne crois pas
qu'il y ait une stratégie pensée d'andré
déploiement en entre temps c'étaient les
populations craignent ces ponts au
conduisent les mêmes erreurs de
communication qui ont conduit à ce
conflit de perception du popu faye la
conception internationaux et les
perceptions locale aujourd'hui c'est
beau une véritable communication de la
part des partenaires européens eux mêmes
en premier lieu la france mais aussi de
la part des partenaires africains qui
font la demande expresse vous allez
entendre le président macky sall dira
que les partenaires africains ne
pourront pas tous à craquer au
terrorisme maintenant c'est le
redéploiement du côté du niger mais
aussi après bien entendu vers les pays
du golfe de guinée qui en feront la
demande si je cite les propos des
marcquois mais des communiqués je pense
tous à la pause et d'être accompagné une
forme de pédagogie pour que non
seulement
les militaires français les partenaires
européens les partenaires africains
puissent gagner la guerre contre les
terroristes mais aussi la paix avec les
populations locales et avec pédagogie
merci beaucoup bakary sondés merci pour
ces éléments de compréhension je
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
régional du à timbuktu institute à à
dacca merci à vous un mot maintenant au
sujet de notre confrère le journaliste
khaled rare ni le parquet d'alger reculs
lourds de peine à son encontre plus de
deux ans prison ferme elles les
autorités l'accusent entre autres
d'incitation attroupement non armés et
atteinte à l'unité nationale
le jugement de ce nouveau procès sera
connu 3 mars prochain khaled rare ni
couvre en fait les marches du ra qu'il
estime n'avoir fait que son travail
après avoir passé 11 mans détention il
avait été gracié par le président
tebboune en février 2021
cette image maintenant celle de
barthélémy dias investi à la mairie de
dakar il remportait en janvier dernier
elle et municipales dans la capitale
sénégalaise à ceux opposant farouche
opposant même au président macky sall
est prêt dit-il à tendre la main au chef
de l'état sous certaines conditions je
propose de l'écouter il répondait aux
questions des limes ndao j invite l'état
à une collaboration sincère avec pour
objectif de belles réalisations pour
l'ensemble des dakarois je ne suis pas à
la tête de la mairie de dakar à un poste
de combat contre les institutions de
l'état en revanche je m'opposerai par
tous les moyens en ma possession à toute
tentative que pourraient père prêter des
opposants à la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales
d'autres temps forts de ce jeudi cette
réunion au sommet à bruxelles les
dirigeants européens africains appelés à
réinventer leur partenariat quelques
heures donc après les annonces faites
depuis le palais de l'elysée au delà du
défi sécuritaire les sujets sont
nombreux l'épidémie de kovy dette une
priorité dans la mesure où seulement 6 %
de la population sur le continent
africain est entièrement vaccinées à ce
jour l'union européenne s'engage par
ailleurs à donner davantage de doses de
vaccins autres engagements pris
l'investissement de 150 milliards
d'euros sur sept ans un soutien aux
projets voulus et porté par les
africains dis-toi bruxelles
convoité aussi par les monarchies du
golfe le continent attire les
investisseurs de la région 300
entreprises émirati sont aujourd'hui
implantées en afrique elles fleurissent
dans les secteurs de l'immobilier des
communications du transport et des
énergies renouvelables
illustration avec la société à mes
avoirs qui opèrent au togo est un
reportage d'emmanuel sodji emmanuel
landais pour france 24
c'est à blitta au coeur du togo là où le
réseau électrique était défaillant que
la société émirati a mais a implanté sa
première centrale solaire en afrique sur
une vingtaine d'hectares pour une
exploitation de 25 ans depuis une
dizaine de mois cinq mille panneaux
solaires suivent toute la journée la
direction du soleil via un capteur
électronique une techno logis unique en
afrique de l'ouest pouvons avoir une
augmentation de production à peu près 10
à 20% de la production initiale qui
étaient près de cent cinquante mille
foyers bénéficient ainsi de
l'électricité sans coupure pendant la
journée la proximité de la centrale et
sa capacité à donner du courant
continuent à peser lourd dans
l'implantation de cette entreprise son
patron est à la tête d'une des plus
grandes sociétés de fabrication de gaz
cinq cent mille bouteilles par an pour
le marché local et l'export comme on a
su qui va voir l'énergie en continu et
le joug et l'année nous pouvons produit
il ya plus de 21%
le togo redouble d'efforts pour attirer
les investisseurs afin d'atteindre
l'accès universel à l'électricité d'ici
à 2030 et avec l'appui des fonds
d'investissement émirati les projets se
développent beaucoup plus vite de son
côté as mais bénéficie d'un site gratuit
de facilité de raccordement au réseau
électrique existant d'exonérations
fiscales et de la possibilité de
transférer ses profits à l'étranger
aujourd'hui la production d'énergie
essaie de combler le trou entre la
demande et le marché malheureusement
cette production d'énergie n'est pas
rentable parfois elle est très cher dans
certaines zones et a des effets sur
l'environnement c'est pour cela que nous
avons mis en place des initiatives comme
celle des théâtres 7 en afrique avec un
partenariat public privé dont le but est
de fournir de l'énergie propre pour 100
millions de personnes avant 2035 les
émirats arabes unis et veulent faire
partie intégrante du futur de l'afrique
le montant des investissements est
estimé à 104 milliards de dollars en
2020 l'egypte d'azur le maroc sont en
tête de liste suivie par des pays
d'afrique subsaharienne comme le nigeria
le mali ou le sénégal la rdc devient
également un partenaire majeur avec le
lancement il ya deux semaines de la
construction d'un port en eau profonde à
banana
c'est la fin du journal de l'afrique
merci à vous de votre fidélité est avec
nous l'information continue sur france 5
[Musique]